I was going to say have you had anybody
who just straight stolen your style I
mean all the time yeah that [__] happens
weekly you know what I mean people tag
me and [__] that people will do is like
third eyye [__] or smiley face [__] you
know I remember um fashion Nova had
dropped the whole line and they dropped
some third eyye Smiley [__] and I tried
to hit them up um I was actually going
to go over one of their Billboards they
had down in Hollywood I was going to
[__] blast that [__] that hard um but
I got a fear of height so I'm not doing
that [__] that [__] was way too high I
actually went there like twice it's on
the second time I was like all right I'm
going to go up there but I was like the
billboard was right above uh like a
fence that had the [__] like the
spikes and [__] oh yeah you're like if I
fall backwards yeah I'm like I'm not
risking this [__] Final Destination yeah
I'd rather hit like one of the home boy
to [__] go hit this [__] yo they
steal so much yeah they do them Sheen
like all those companies dude they steal
so much from like small like small
artists small creators like small
clothing lines even they'll steal a
[__] clothing line design there's no
way they didn't see my [__] dude it was
a third eyy smiley face where else you
going to see that [__] with like with
like like drippy like exactly my
everything was crazy and I was like
everybody was tagging me in it I was
like these [__] you know what
I'm saying I'm like like it's cool I've
had a lot of people you know try to bite
this [__] and maybe maybe you know it's
possible that [__] just got the
same idea it's possible that they you
know I'm you know what it is too is your
your work's so popular people will see
it and not even care to see like oh what
is this what is this from they just see
it and then they're like oh we're just
going to replicate this without thinking
of of you [__] will get
inspired and they run and do their own
[__] I mean I would have loved to even
just you know had the conversation of
doing a legit collab it was like bro we
can make so much more by just doing this
legitimately you know what I mean but um
yeah people bite this [__] all the time
and it was funny when I when when Wes
hit me up you know he he immediately
responded to the third eye [__] that was
what he liked and he goes um dude it's
the craziest [__] because I had read I
had discovered who Wes and Conway was in
an article about them sh signing a shady
and at the time you know I was following
a lot of hip-hop Pages you know kind of
trying to stay up to date with what was
going on um cuz I started putting a lot
of music out in like 2018 and you know
writing a lot and um so I was trying to
stay up to date and I saw that article
and I looked into their music I was like
damn these [__] are dope had no
idea who they were I was like these
dudes obviously like I probably had the
same impression as everybody else right
away it spoke wuang but I was like I
thought these dudes were like some old
heads that I just never heard of right
right right um and then fast forward
that was like in June June or July of
2017 fast forward to September I get a
DM from West because hip hop DX posted
my Tupac painting so he was like Yo dude
he's like I [__] with your [__] he was
like you know I just bought a new crib I
want to acquire some work he asked what
I had you know nothing really spoke to
him at the time and he was like let me
think about it and then he hits me back
up like a month or two later he's like
I'm about to drop an album at the top of
2018 and I want you to do the cover and
I was like all right bet like we could
do that and it was the first time I had
ever been you know offered to do a like
a an album cover like something legit
and uh I was like what do you have in
mind and he goes I want to do a portrait
of Chris Ben Juan with the third eye and
I was like oh [__] I like all right we
can run that so and I was already
building uh a body of work for a show
that year so when I did that cover and
it came out it just elevated every the
whole body work that I was doing yeah
hype Beast picked it up and they were
talking about it so that was it was a
crazy cosign and um but nobody really at
the time I wasn't like I didn't have
that big of a IG following I actually I
didn't have ig5 I probably had like
10,000 followers so very few people
right right so when they saw my third
eye series a lot of people thought I was
biting Wes they just thought that I was
they were like realize that you're yeah
like I would get a lot of people in my
com is being like damn this [__] looks
like Westside gun [__] or this
[__] I'm like and I just like at
the beginning I would have to like
explain to people and then I just
started now when it h it still happens
when it happens I'm just like man shit's
funny cuz I'm like [__] stupid
they just don't know but that but that's
why it's like you know my Ig is [__]
like from top to bottom it's just build
with Westside [__] so I'm like how do
you not know you know I mean like it's
been six years now like how do you how
are you not caught up but um yeah it's
funny so you know a lot of people
because Wes put that [__] out a lot of
people started copying it the smile
especially the smiley face thing you
know I'll see a lot of people doing
portraits of Wes with like a third eye
with like smiley faces and [__] in the
background and and it wasn't like a
thing like I'm going to paint third eyes
and smiley faces and that's what's going
to that's what's going to hit it just it
just happened you know and people
responded to it really well I was going
to say uh for you like I know that you
know you just did a commission piece for
peasy the fat the fat Jo uh piece like
if somebody hits you uh you don't have
to give us your business but like what
like what's the conversation start at if
you if they want to commission a pece
with you well I mean yeah let's just say
some dude off the street who just wants
you to paint yeah I mean I'll put you on
game I mean you know I get hit up the
art game is just so interesting to me
because you hear like there's these apps
you could buy pieces of art you can buy
shares of art there's the gallery game
there's so many like it's just like it's
it's kind of like the music game there's
just so many different yeah I think I
think during 2020 though I kind of um it
it things change I'm telling you like a
lot of [__] changed for me in 2020 that
there was a lot of things that happened
that elevated everything that I was
doing and I kind of beat the gallery
system especially the galleries that I
was working with at the time um up until
you know then I had never had
representation I had exhibited my work
in tons of galleries some museums but
you know I kind of you know I kind of
skipped a lot of steps um during that
time because when pray for Paris came
out I had a lot of attention uh having
done the alternate cover that Virgil did
so a lot of people uh you know had their
eyes on and I sold a lot of work by
myself you know I I never had an art
dealer never had an advisor or any type
of manager representative so you know my
my process was very like like it became
on like on some trapping [__] you know
that's that's how like a lot of the [__]
that's what it felt like like I felt
like the last four or five years I've
been trapping my [__] just straight
straight up like there's no the formula
is so simple like I don't even know how
to explain it to people in simpler terms
you you know people think that there's
some sort of crazy formula and I'm like
nah dude it just sort of happened where
it it was pretty it's organic you know
Wes hit me when Wes hit me up it was as
simple as yo dude I want to work with
you and I was a fan of him and I was
like yeah let's do it you know there was
no contract there was no business
meeting it was like what you what do
what do you want to run you know sent me
some some images I was like all right
let's run this one we did it gave them a
price and that was it and then and
that's just is super straightforward you
know like so I don't do projects for
just anybody I so not anybody can just
hit you no like in the beginning maybe
but a quickly started to realize that
you know I had the opportunity to say no
to a lot of [__] you know in the
beginning CU what is like if you say yes
to something what is the time that it
takes to put one of your paintings
together it just depends on the project
it depends on you know what I got going
on at the time if I'm already working on
a bunch of [__] I'm saying like in terms
of just like hours man hours actual
painting I mean it you know it depends
on how big the piece is how much detail
there is I mean I can bust out a
painting pretty quickly if I really put
everything aside say the Fat Joe Wi well
Fat Joe is um that's a 5x5 painting 5T
by 5T I think I did that [__] in like
like 30 Days Like A month's time but I
was taking breaks there was stuff that
was happening in between but you know
it's like when Wes hits me up and he's
like yo I need this [__] by yesterday
I'm like on a 3-day timeline like I got
so you'll tweak out and just finish dude
straight 12h hour days just back to back
nonstop yeah like when I did um when I
did the Jordan and Virgil portrait I did
those both in like three days like to
collectively yeah like Virgil took me
like one day and then Jordan took me two
days but that's that's because I had to
I don't think it really matters how fast
or long it takes for someone to create
something um I could work very quickly
just because I know like once I start
I'm locked in it's like it's like a
rapper it's like you know when they jump
into a studio it's like they already got
the material laid out just give them a
[__] beat and once they're in they're
in you know what I mean it's not like uh
you know and then you got some of these
artists who take you know a year or two
years to make a project cuz they're
they're like taking their time they're
Reminiscing on it with me I could just
jump into it I'm already especially when
Wes hits me up cuz when West hits me up
it's like it's Synergy like that energy
just I get locked into it and already
I'm already on I'm already on it you
know there's no there's nothing that's
going to uh slow me down when I'm
working on his projects but um yeah I
don't you know I don't take on just any
projects I quickly started to say no to
a lot of [__] you know I keep the I keep
the the the the group of people that
collect my [__] is very tight you know
there is a weight list you know there
there is a a process sort of an
valuation process to get my [__] now oh
that's sick you know what I mean and I
mean that's a good place to be in yeah
it is but you know it all and and I get
it you know I know everybody wants it
but that's why I started you know doing
the prints allows people to acquire my
work on on a scale that's you know it's
like not everybody's going to afford a
$30 $40,000 painting but you know the
prints it allows the work to be
accessible for everybody and that's that
was you know important for me to to
establish because I want everybody to
have my [__] yeah you know what I mean
but the the the original [__] is like
that's you know that's reserved for you
got to come it's like you got to come
correct you I get a lot of people
that'll that'll hit me up and they
they'll assume that the work is I mean I
really don't care what the price of [__]
goes for but you know it took me a long
time to get to where I'm at and you know
I I it's hard to explain that to
everybody and then when people hit me
him and they're like oh what's your work
going for and I'll give them a number
and they're like damn that shit's crazy
like I thought you know I gotta wait a
while and I'm like well you know you
it's cool that you didn't know it's fine
but I'm like you know what do you expect
like you're hit me up because you you
see that Wes [__] with me pey [__]
with me I'm doing [__] for [__] Benny
I'm doing [__] for all these people and
doing collabs with so and so I'm like
come on what do you expect like don't
you know what I mean that's why I got
certain things pinned on my page so
[__] know like you're not going
to go to so and so you know super
established and just well yeah you're
not going to go to like ask timberin for
a beat and then surprised when he tries
to hit you upside the head yeah and I'm
like I'm I wouldn't even you know so but
it takes people to ask so they know so
you know what I mean but that's why I'm
like you know they I I don't know people
I guess they don't really do their
research I mean you could find the price
of [__] on like artsy you know my shit's
there you know